look at that sun coming
currently on the top of the van to get
the most out of that sun
because yeah you might have seen last
time it rains quite a bit raining a lot
even this week was all rain but today is
a good sunny day
so we need to get the most out of that
and i was thinking
in the morning i like to walk around to
run but i always end up running sort of
the big roads there are a few big roads
in the land
which is nice but in a way you want to
make sure you can go
reach every place but a lot of things
now are
kind of wild a lot of thorns or grown
with bushes
so it's hard to really make a pot so i
was thinking today might be a good time
to make pathways
just small ones but then from then i
just keep walking them or running them
every day
maybe even cycling them and slowly they
become more
sturdy parts
so for today's tools we have cutter
saw and the shovel
but first we have breakfast
and after all these years it finally
really makes sense
to wear my wood chopper
jacket yeah
now we can start
[Applause]
so let's start by going up the highest
point which is those rocks
so we need to go through the bushes
somewhere here
oops
so there are quite a lot of dead trees
that's because a few years ago there was
a big forest fire here
so that's why now you see a lot of young
trees sprouting up
so
i think it's areas like here where you
have a lot of bushes where you can just
create a pot
and i think if you walk it every day you
can really create like a solid
clean pot without stuff growing
but there are big rocks almost there
spiky bushes don't like them
[Applause]
we're almost at the big rock just a few
more dead trees to move
so
okay we're almost there big rocks are
there we just have to go
straight through these bushes
right so we made it to the top rocks
are here my van is somewhere down there
i don't know if you can see it um took a
bit longer than expected especially this
last part
because there are a lot of these thorns
here
and they're pretty painful aggressive
and spiky
so i don't think i will be able to
finish the full run
today i think it's going to be a more um
longer term project
so that week the weather went back to
rain
and i continued to make the pathway
so i was chopping this pathway here
look at those weird chili mushrooms
all right job is done
bit wet also shoe situation still not
very good
very wet
still has some dry areas
and besides this not being the best rain
shoe i also noticed there's actually
quite a big
hole in here and another one
in here yeah i need to get rubber boots
end of the week the pot is finished
so finally let me show you guys the
route so we're gonna start in the camp
and then we go there
into the tunnel
so here we have the lake
still can be cleaned up but at least we
can access properly
this is not my proudest part but there
were so many cheese so i still have to
chop them but we can go
over them
now we have to go to the right but on
the left
you can also see this lake
like the green water just to have a look
at it but we need to go there
so here we're back on the main road it
goes up and down
and this is where we started last time
chopping going straight in
very bushy area
this is where all the dead trees were
lots of spiky bushes
we have a good viewpoint up here
you know let's go up the big one and
this rock is a pretty good
viewpoint well if it's a bit less cloudy
and the road we made came from
there then up up up here
and then hey and now from here we're
going
down there to the big grass patch
all right goodbye rock we're going
further down
here we are back on the main road
may not left but we have to go right
now we go sharp left
and then we lick the little pathway here
on the right
now we're on the big grass patch and
from here is just a bit freestyle
on the left side here
there's a water stream going
let's take a look at it
back to the freestyle
now we have to go over there to the
swamp
straight across the grass patch
right over here is the swamp or
potential swimming pool right there
very and then we go up here
here were the jelly mushrooms
and now we are at the workspace area
back to the main road
here we are back in the base camp all
right so that was the third update
if you want to see the previous updates
make sure to go there
and if you want to see all the updates
that are still coming make sure to
subscribe to this channel
and yeah if you want to help us out or
make sure i can buy rubber boots
make sure to visit
support.projectcom.com
to see how you can help out thanks for
watching and see you in the next video